hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast
I'm your host Sean Carroll if any of you
have read my book the big picture you
know I make a big deal in there about
different ways of talking about the
universe this is a very old idea that's
been talked about in different ways
itself as it were but the point is that
there is sort of a way of talking about
the universe at the fundamental physical
level or you might talk about a
wavefunction or quantum fields or
something like that and then there are
emergent levels on top of that there's
sort of a biological level where they're
cells and organs and so forth individual
organisms there's kind of a human level
with psychology and there's even
superhuman levels where you talk about
sociology or politics or economics or
whatever and everyone kind of agrees
that those levels exist but the
relationship between them can be a
tricky one in particular there can be a
little bit of reluctance in some circles
to think of human beings as stuff that
just obeys the laws of physics on the
other hand there is a tendency in other
circles to what I would call over claim
the extent to which we should just think
of ourselves as things obeying the laws
of physics in the sense that we should
not abandon or modify the vocabulary of
fundamental physics even when we talk
about individual people as I explained
in the book you obviously need to have
consistency between how we talk about
people and how we talked about particles
but the vocabularies the ideas that we
may use might be very different no where
does that become more obvious in the
discussions we have about free will and
of course there are different
definitions of free will blah blah blah
but regardless of your favorite
definitions there's an interesting
amount of work to be done trying to
establish how we should talk about
people how we should think about them
how we should involve values and morals
and ethics how we should punish them how
we should assign praise and blame so
today we're talking to Jenna Ismael
who's a philosopher at Columbia
University about this exact problem
about how to think about human beings
while accepting the fact that human
beings are part
of the physical world this is very much
in my wheelhouse in terms of interest
it's not so much my wheelhouse in terms
of expertise so it's a very useful
conversation for people like me who care
about connecting humanity to the
fundamental laws of physics in some way
it's a the last element of a trilogy in
the last three podcast we've had Dan
Dennett and then Sarah Amar'e Walker and
today Janine and in the talk with Dan we
talked about the very general idea of
connecting the scientific image to the
manifest image in the talk with Sarah we
did that in the case of life where is
the dividing line between non life and
life how do you make those connections
how do you make that transition so today
in some sense we're doing that with
people how do you draw that difference
between what's a person what's not a
person what does it matter to be a
person all while respecting the rules
laid down by the fundamental laws of
physics I also want to mention before we
dive into the conversation that I'm
going to be traveling to Australia New
Zealand at the end of February
I usually don't mention my trips and
talks and things like that on the
podcast but maybe I should do it more
often so anyway end of February 2020 for
those of you listening in the future I'm
going to be in Auckland
Brisbane Sydney and Melbourne giving
some talks sponsored by think Inc sadly
it's not free but I don't often go to
Australia New Zealand so this is a
chance to see me if you want to buy
books you can do that if you want to get
books signed if you already have them
you can do that and you can look at the
web page for think ink which is the
organisation putting on these talks it's
think ink i NC org a you for Australia
and there I am anyone down there who
might be listening I hope to see you
there so this is gonna be a good
conversation at the boundaries of
physics and philosophy I don't think
there are any such boundaries I think
there's a middle ground and that's
solely where we are today
so let's go
[Music]
and then Ismail welcomed with mindscape
podcast thank you for having me
so freewill is a topic that people talk
about a lot and everyone has an opinion
about right it's it's an amazing extent
to which people have very fervent
opinions I worry a little bit that a lot
of the debate comes down to definitions
so I actually personally tried to avoid
talking about freewill that much but you
wrote a whole book about it was that
like a courageous act to dive into these
waters where everyone has a pre-existing
opinion I think I didn't actually go
diving into the waters having a kind of
dog in the fight about what I thought
about it I mean I think for me it comes
out of the places kind of in our
worldview especially a physicalist
worldview where it's clear there's
something that we don't understand I
think for me thinking about free will it
was sort of a placeholder for that sense
of agency that we have everybody even
pre theoretically even before they
decide on a definition of what free will
is supposed to be when they're presented
with the fact of determinism feel
shocked and in some cases offended and
so it's clear that there's something in
the concept of determinism that clashes
even pre theoretically with our sense of
you know who we are and the way that we
fit into the cosmos and because I'm not
a moral psychologist I'm not philosopher
with you know already a dog in that
fight I just felt like there was
something clear that needed to be
understood and relating it to physics
yeah the way the reason for relating it
to physics was because physics gives us
a sort of regimented context both within
which we can sort of raise the question
in a precise form and then see about
going to you know trying to address it
and I think so probably many listeners
are familiar with the general landscape
of arguments that on the one hand people
say well look we have laws of physics
they're impersonal we don't get to
overrule them just because we're a
person
not Cartesian dualism therefore
everything is determined and there's no
free will and there's some other people
who say yes but we can be compatible
lists about laws of physics and free
will there's some emergent property some
higher levels these are things that I
say in in my own books
so just to spoil you know the end of the
of the movie here why don't you situate
yourself within that context a little
bit and then we'll back up and try to
fill things in okay I mean I think I do
I do think that a certain kind of
freedom is completely compatible with
the laws of physics I tried not to get
into this sort of positioning myself
with respect to the philosophical
landscape because what I try to do in
the book is actually I understand and I
believe and think that physics is going
to change our conceptions of you know
what kinds of thing we are and how we
fit into the world so instead of
starting with some definition of what
freewill is and seeing whether physics
matches that I try to understand what
physics is telling us about ourselves
and what sorts of freedom if you think
of yourself as a physical thing in the
physical world
you end up having without really arguing
that that's what we you know what what
always men have always meant or pre
theoretically whether it fits our
conceptions of freedom by pre
theoretically you've used this term it
means you know before we think very hard
about yeah intuitively without before
you settle on you know philosophical
view about what freedom would have to be
right in the manifest image in the folk
psychology or whatever yeah yeah before
you get sophisticated okay but so you do
want to say I mean your books title is
how physics makes us free so you're not
on the side that says there's no such
thing as free will that's right although
the title of the book is ambiguous in
all kinds of ways that are intended so
for example how the way in which physics
makes us free right so the specific
kinds of freedom that physics gives us
that's right so it's rather than saying
do or do we not have free will it's what
does it mean to say or what does it mean
to have or feel that we have this kind
of freedom in mind right in what kinds
of ways do we have freedom if we
conceive of ourselves as physical things
in a physical world okay so now everyone
has made up their mind whether they
agree with you or not already
but let's still nevertheless fill things
in I did recently do podcasts both with
Ned Hall where we talked a lot about
possible worlds and a little bit about
causation and one was Dan Dennett
where we talked a little bit about
freewill and things like that but in
both cases you know there were whirlwind
tours of a lot of territory so this is
our chance to dig in a little bit more
so don't think that all the interesting
things have been said but you know
people have been thinking about these
things so you have a very simple
organization in your book where you sort
of first talk about what it means to be
a person to have a self compatible with
the laws of physics and then you start
talking about what it means to have
agency to be able to cause things and
and do things so does that sound like a
sensible organization for the discussion
as well yes first talk about the self
okay good
what does it mean to be a person to be a
self to be an agent if we know that
we're just a bunch of atoms obeying the
standard model of particle physics lots
of questions I mean I think the thing
the thing that seems to me
characteristic of the self is what I
take from sort of des cartes original
discussion so Descartes says when he
introduces the notion of the self into
philosophical discourse in the way that
it appears today he says what is this
thing this I whose existence is made
known to me in the very act of trying to
deny that it exists so in a way what
he's doing is he's saying I'm not
starting with any idea of what I am
except that I am that thing whose
existence I cannot myself deny and it
seems to be suggested if you sort of
peel apart the layers in the argument
there that what I am is first and
foremost the the the owner of a
reflexive consciousness so what I try to
thinks about themselves someone who is
able to entertain thoughts about
themselves as the subject of thoughts
yeah so what I do in the book is spend
the first part of the book trying to
understand how a consciousness of that
kind arises so instead of starting out
with a view of particles in the void and
trying to say which particle or
configurations of particle
particles and would answer to that
description I started out with particles
in the void and and and tried to come to
some understanding of first of the
emergence of complex systems and then
the emergence of things like cognizes
and then the emergence of the kinds of
things that have the cognitive
organization that allows them to think
about their own thoughts and think about
themselves as a subject of thought and
then that gets to be the environment
within which we have the sort of you
know AI thoughts that that can raise
questions about themselves and their
place in the world and ultimately
questions about free will and so just so
people don't get too distracted but your
consciousness per se is not your target
here right you're not tackling the hard
problem of consciousness no deliberately
avoiding it okay but we would like to
say so okay good so we're particles in
the void which is a poetic way of saying
we we are things that obey the laws of
physics and those things come together
to make self conscious creatures agents
I don't know what your favorite word is
soul okay lets you know indulge
ourselves a little bit what what do you
say or think about the actual process
that that happens over time you mean
about the like in the long term
evolutionary history the emergence of so
sorry for any question I asked please
answer the most interesting version of
the question I was trying to ask in the
gaps that I don't necessarily mention
yeah okay so a very potted sort of
schematic view about how one might think
of the emergence of agencies you know we
start out with systems that I'm sorry we
started out with particles that band
together into self-organizing units
eventually the units at least the ones
that are selected for have to do more
complex things that require them to do
things like metabolize energy from the
environment it turns out to be
advantageous for creature for systems
like that systems that is to say that
have to gather energy and metabolize it
to be able to gather information and
track there and control and track their
own movements through the landscape
turns out to be it turns out sorry later
that for more and more sophisticated
ways of gathering and you
information lead from very simple sorts
of systems like amoeba through things
like worms through things like dogs and
cats and ultimately to creatures like us
who have a very special kind of
equipment that's specifically designed
to process and gather large bodies of
information put that information to use
in in the service of guiding behavior
patricia churchland once pointed out to
me a recent paper from people who were
studying C elegans the little round word
you know the model system in biology
where they because we know all the
neurons right and we're still trying to
figure out what they're good for what
they do and the claim was this one
neuron its job or at least half of its
job was to distinguish self from other
it basically told the little C elegans
worm whether a certain force acting on
it was exogenous or endogenous and the
grandiose claim was that that was the
birth of self-awareness in creatures and
whether or not that's specifically true
that's the kind of explanation you're
signing on to very very scientific based
one that's exactly right I mean I think
for for me it's a more kind of cognitive
based distinction the distinction
between self and world so Minds like
ours Minds that is to say we're a large
part a large amount of the neural
machinery is devoted specifically to
processing and routing information are
best described in cognitive terms that
is using the information theoretic
vocabulary that comes naturally when
you're describing lines and the process
you know something like this we are you
know sort of immediate what's first in
the order of awareness is perceptual
information the perceptual information
contains a lot of information kind of
about us and are in our situation in the
environment we spend a lot of time or
the brain spends a lot of kind of
cognitive energy separating the
information that's about the way the
environment is on its own independently
of us from information about the way in
which were situated in the environment
and that process of kind of separating
self from world or better separating
formation about self from information
about the world is the process in which
you know our notions of ourselves and
our notions of the world does the
objective environment through which we
move get articulated and firmed up one
of my favourite sponsors here on
mindscape is the great courses plus it's
a streaming service that gives you
access to college-level courses taught
by some of the best professors and
teachers from the best universities and
academic institutions in the world
I've taught there myself I love all the
courses that they have one that you
might be interested in is called black
hole's tides and curved space-time
understanding gravity taught by
Professor Benjamin
Schumacher gravity is funny because it's
all around us we experience it every day
but in the post
Einstein world there are a lot of things
about gravity that surprised us that
challenge our intuition if you want to
understand black holes the warping of
space-time the bending of light the Big
Bang this is the course for you so you
can unlock a world knowledge with the
great courses plus four mindscape
listeners we have a special offer three
months of unlimited access for just $30
but to get this limited time offer you
must sign up today using the special URL
the great courses plus comm slash
mindscape that's th e great courses PL
us comm slash mindscape
so do you in the process of writing a
book or just thinking about this in
doing research
how much biology literature do you read
I mean do you dig into evolution and
neuroscience and things like that is
that relevant it's relevant for sure I
didn't do much of it in the book it's
the little kind of potted history I told
about the emergence of cells I mean
that's a story that's biological through
and through the the you know the
questions of what are selected for and
the routes by which creatures like us
develop that's entirely biology the
neuroscience I tend to think for the
reasons that I said that the more the
the more important and immediately
relevant vocabulary for for
understanding the kinds of creatures
that we are in ways that we will
recognize from a first-person
perspective
is cognitive science and I tend to think
the neuroscience is relevant but in
evolutionary terms it's really our
brains worth the low-level process the
note low-level neural processes in our
brains such as they are were selected
because they support the sort of high
level cognitive processing that that
they support and so I tend to think that
it's more illuminating for my purposes
to talk about the cognitive processing
and think of the lower the low-level
neural processing description is falling
into place so the difference the
distinction is neuroscience is really
about you know the neurons and how they
hook up for some cognitive sciences more
high-level structures in the brain and
specifically structures that are
described in functional terms in terms
of the way that they route information
okay so but I guess my job since I'm
broadly sympathetic to what you say into
my job for the purposes of this
conversation is to channel the people
who are not and I'll probably do a
crappy job at that but I'll give it my
best shot
so just in terms of vocabulary in that
potted history there's a whole bunch of
things that creep in right I mean
there's a bunch of atoms that are
bumping into each other but then we
start using words like usefulness and
purpose and stuff like that is there a
philosophy problem associated with the
legitimacy of using those words so there
is I mean one of the you know one wants
to start with the most austere physical
description that one can and earn one's
right to use notions like purpose by
adding structure into that setting
there's a long history of people sort of
legitimately and uncritically employing
words that that one only earns one's
right that sorry that have a proper
place only once one's got a mind you
know forming intentions and so on in
place and then using that to describe
the actions of or the behaviors of atoms
in the void or something farther down
the biological so phylogenetic scale so
one has to be very careful about that
the right order in which to do things is
to start with a very
dear non purpose Laden vocabulary
introduced notions of purpose as they
become applicable so there are very
stripped-down notions of purpose that
that come into effect and applicability
when you have systems that were selected
and depend on doing things like you know
getting food and avoiding prey and you
get more articulate notions as you get
cognitive systems on on you know in
place and even more sophisticated and
ultimately the ones that that matter for
the human being
notions in place when you have creatures
that are deliberately representing to
themselves possible situations forming
long term goals and choosing between
them on the basis of you know sort of
information and you end and and desires
and so on okay so I think that that
helps understand you know the stages at
which these different terms become
useful but let's you know let's again be
a little hard nosed and say why is it
even legitimate like is couldn't someone
just say that using a vocabulary of
purposes is just giving in to allusions
like there's no purposes in the laws of
physics so what what legitimates using
that even at a higher level
so I'm gonna I'm gonna take a leaf from
your cat's at the fundamental level in
principle we could describe things all
in terms of just you know the vocabulary
that physics uses it wouldn't be very
illuminating you know and especially to
the extent that the goal here is to find
structures and creatures that we
recognize from a first-person point of
view as applicable to ourselves in our
mental lives and our actions then we are
gonna have to introduce that vocabulary
at some stage right okay and even if we
don't solve the problem of consciousness
there's still we still need a rough
picture of what's going on in our brains
right you know you talk a lot about
Daniel Dennett's views in the book and
you sort of agree with him largely but
not entirely but you know what
need to take from how the brain works to
be able to have this discussion about
agents making choices we need a broadly
functional understanding of you know
sort of the emergent processes that
support things like decision so we need
to be able to think of ourselves as
collecting information storing that
information making decisions based on
information
none of that requires solving the
problem of consciousness in the sense
that it's come in to the come in to the
philosophical literature and come to be
known as the hard problem the hard
problem is specifically the residue
that's left over after you give a
complete functional description of the
brain so we yeah so as long as we know
how to talk about the brain in terms of
what it does you know pushing our bodies
around and making decisions and so forth
we don't need to worry about niceties
about it's the experience of the redness
of red okay but the brain but an
important insight here is that we are
not little homunculus right we're not
unified the you know whether it's
evolution or neuroscience or cognitive
science or philosophy there's a lot of
reasons to believe that it's kind of a
mess inside our brains kind of an unruly
a corporation is actually how you put it
right that's right yes so I think yes
and no or yes but no so it's absolutely
true that at the bottom level were not
unified at all I mean there's nothing in
physics but particles were made of
collections of particles they're banked
bound together and loose coalition's and
configurations we gain and lose them all
time and even when we look at the mind
using cognitive vocabulary at the bottom
levels were a bunch of sensory motor
subsystems cobbled together to produce
emergent behavior but what I argue in
the book and what I think is correct and
what I think is essential to having a
concept of self of the kind that we do
there is a kind of late addition to this
loose coalition of sensory motor
subsystems that that has the structure
of something like an you know an
executive board that collects the
information and oversees
and makes things like All Things
Considered decisions about what to do
and I think that when you know when when
we're not just operating on the basis of
responding to hunger or appetites but
we're actually taking all of our desires
you know into account and making in all
things considered judgment about what to
do the I there who yields the decision
after taking all those things into
account that to me is a unified thing
and its role is precisely to unify or to
in some sense collectivize the
operations of all of the low-level parts
did I ever tell you about the time I
took LSD Jennifer my wife wrote a book
on the science of self and we were told
that if we really wanted to she was told
it if she really was understand the
science of self he has to take LSD and
see how that affects yourself and she
was told that the you know the ego
dissolves and so forth and yourself is
not there but and so as a good scientist
and husband I went along and we did this
together
but we both agreed at the end of the day
there's still an eye like there's still
some final not maybe not decision making
process that's that's too laden but like
you said an executive board like the the
editor who puts the different drafts
together in Dennis language yeah yeah
that's exactly right I mean I think for
me things like a jury are a good model
so in some sense if you walk into a jury
room it's like a coffin II of different
voices arguing and competing but when
the jury issues a decision the decision
is issued in the voice of the jury not
in any one of the jurors so it's
absolutely true I think that if we sort
of reflect on what our mental lives are
like a lot of the times it's as noisy
and as unruly and as a jury with as
little apparent apparent unity as a jury
but when we issue a decision it comes
from the jury as a whole as a body and I
think that's that's the kind of thing
that we are we as subjects of decision
and conte and intention and so
and we are used to this way of thinking
all the time when it comes to
corporations or Nations or something
like that you know we say a nation made
a decision right even though there's a
bunch of voices going on at the end of
the day laws are passed or actions are
taken right and let me point out that
given the early questions that you
started with namely that you know the
world's ultimately you know dissolves
into a bunch of little particles the
notion of an organization is exactly the
right one in order that we need to
understand higher-level emergent sorts
of systems in what sense can you
elaborate on that we are organizations
of the bits of which matter is made okay
right so we are composed of those bits
but those bits become us only when
they're organized in a very particular
way I guess one of the you know one of
the arguments used by freewill deflation
asur whatever their their label is is
you know if you could pinpoint where in
the brain decision was being made and
understand that process either in
physics or in neuroscience or just in
biology then we should stop calling it a
decision being made in some sense right
like I guess that's the point of view
that people who get very excited about
libbets experiments would take I don't
even know what I've got just sounds
absurd to me I mean it seems to me when
you pinpoint that if there is a
particular locus of decision that can be
identified and I also I see no reason
our priori to suppose that those
processes aren't completely distributed
but if we could find a particular point
that's the locus of a decision it seems
to me you've just identified the neural
basis for decision right so but there's
I just want it I totally agree but I
want to emphasize the philosophical
importance of the move be made here we
just because we correlate what's what we
call the decision to something going on
in the brain doesn't mean that the
decision went away right you know dude
it's still there at that level of
description is that you know it's still
the correct emergent higher level way of
talking is that affair that's exactly
right
you've just found what the sub structure
of decision looks like at the neural
level I want to pause to talk about joy
Bird furniture this is the place to go
for furniture for
creative people who do not want to be
stymied by the selections that they see
in the showroom at joy bird you can
create your furniture there's over 50
fabric and leather options three
different shades of wood and over 250
unique silhouettes to help you build
their furniture you want joy bird offers
a range of kid and pet friendly
upholstery options so that your
creations will be durable standing the
test of time there are free swatch kits
so you can actually examine all the
different fabrics before you choose and
there are even free personal design
consultants to help you go from
inspiration to creation best of all if
you don't like it you can return it
there's a 365 day home trial you can sit
on it sleep on it break it in if you
don't love your joy bird furniture send
it back if you go to joy word.com slash
mindscape you'll receive an exclusive
offer for 25% off your first order by
using the code mindscape let your
creativity run wild and build the
furniture you were meant to live in and
just just to sort of finish up the
thread that I was pursuing earlier even
vocabulary words like intentionality
you know purpose like we said before
these are our best ways of talking about
what the self is doing in some sense
that's right yeah but as you said you
know we want to be very careful that we
don't import those words before we've
earned the right to use them so I think
in particular so you talked about
purpose before I think those do come in
a very natural way out of biology but
notions like intention when it's used in
the philosophical sense with it with an
S it's imports notion of meaning that
involved normative normative conceptions
of what counts and doesn't count as
getting the right meaning that are very
difficult to understand strictly in
biological terms there I think you need
something like a social environment so
that leap from you know understanding
purpose to understanding intention and
this in this rich sense I think requires
a little bit more
or then then simply situating us you
know the biological self in the
environment and understanding its act
its kind of Commerce with its
environment I mean can you maybe say
more about the role the social
interactions there yeah so it's I don't
know how much more I can say that can be
illuminating but so when I talk about
normative notions of meaning this means
that you can use vocabulary in a way
that counts as right or wrong in a way
that historically has proven very
difficult to cash out simply in terms of
functional interaction between a
biological organism and the environment
when you put a system like us in a
social environment and you have it
communicating that is exchanging
information with other systems that have
their own first personal point of view
there's a lot more structure in that
situation a lot more structure to start
thinking about things like getting it
right and getting it wrong and using a
meaning in a sense that allows it to be
passed and so inter subjectively that
that sort of setting I think brings with
it new things that aren't just there
with with the biological or with with a
purely biological setting good so we
seem to get to be getting this picture
where the self is merchand out of a
noisy collective of individual
biological things going on that
individually are not selves would come
together to make us and yet there's some
decision-maker process anyway at the end
of the day that gives us an identity as
something that makes choices so that you
it can be pinpoint
at the exact stages at which that
vocabulary becomes useful like our cat's
selves our worms cells or bacteria cells
so two different questions here when is
the conceptual question about exactly
what do we require when we think that in
order for that vocabulary to become
applicable and then there's the
empirical question about you know which
of the pretty animals along that that
spectrum exhibit those characteristics
there's so much I started thinking about
this I looked
to the literature on animal cognition
and there's just so much you don't know
yeah so I think the empirical questions
that's why we shouldn't become physicist
it's much easier so much right right
but so the I think the there are
empirical questions that we just don't
know the answer to and I certainly don't
know the answer to as fits a conceptual
question it depends what you mean by a
self I mean you know there's rudimentary
notions of cells that don't require
anything like the formation of thoughts
about oneself we can you know define
those identify them and those mark
important transition points there are
other important transition points that
come later I think you know it's I
prefer not to make choices about you
know with where exactly along that that
those series of transitions the notion
of a self becomes applicable certainly
for the purposes of understanding the
kinds of cells we are the kinds of cells
that possess the cognitive equipment to
entertain those cartesian thought i this
thing whose existence is made known to
me in the very very act of trying to
deny that it exists those are plausibly
only human mm okay that's not certain
there's a lot that we don't know about
higher animals especially things like
whales and dolphins but it seems to be
associated with a whole cascade of that
of capacities that that seem do seem to
be uniquely human so I'm inclined to
think that they are characteristically
and perhaps uniquely human but but you
know just so people don't get too
excited by this not necessarily human
before that yeah there's nothing like
spiritually special about us ever crying
at this point of view yeah but okay let
me I'm gonna deviate from our topic here
because this opens a little can of worms
that is still really really interesting
I did a solo podcast on morality where I
talked about how well I talk I tried to
I tried to come up with the
moral viewpoints that I particularly had
that would get the most disagreement
from my audience or at least you know
from people who cared so one of them was
on vegetarianism I'm not a vegetarian
and but I do have this strong feeling
that non vegetarians such as myself do a
crappy job of giving a philosophically
respectable defense of not being
vegetarian like why so the question in
my mind is why is it bad to kill people
but it's okay to kill cows and eat them
right I think that that's sort of a
necessary thing that everyone should
have an answer to if they if they eat
meat I seem to remember talking to you
about yeah I mean I'm gonna get to
because you have the world's best most
sophisticated decision procedure about
what to eat and what not to eat but the
as we were shoveling yeah so the I mean
I can tell you my own story I was a
vegetarian for about four twenty four
years and it was an article of David
Bellman's that turned me and it came
actually though in the context of having
thought a lot about the self so I became
a vegetarian when I was quite young for
the reason that I didn't understand well
you know why it was okay to kill cows
for example but not okay to kill humans
having come to a kind of relatively
articulate understanding of what it was
for there to be a self I read this
article by bellman in which he gives
this argument almost in passing at the
end of the piece that seemed spot-on
right to me so I'll tell you about the
argument in a second but I want to
preface it by saying that this is an
argument that it's different in kind to
kill cows and it is to kill human beings
but it doesn't in any way license you
and making cows suffer short not very
clear suffering bad try to avoid that
and that's a separate issue whether
there's some moral imperative is not
even to kill the cow right okay so
here's a way of assessing I'm gonna
speak in terms of a value of a life but
I mean that just in the economic sense
adding up the kinds of value that there
can be in a life for all kinds of
creatures any creature with a sort of
experience role
so one can think surely one can count
whether a moment the quality of a moment
for that creature is good or bad and you
can count over any extended period the
aggregate of the quality of moments or
or you can assess the value of that
period in some way that's a function of
the quality of the moments that compose
it but for creatures like us creatures
that have a conception of their pasts in
their future creatures that represent to
themselves goals and plans that extend
over large periods of time we don't just
have a notion of the value of the life
as a unit or longer periods in that life
that's simply a matter of aggregating
the quality of the moments in it in fact
and I think this is entirely right and
this was Bellman's point in the article
we have a conception of the good of a
life or the good of some extended period
of a life that's entirely orthogonals of
the quality of the moments that compose
it and even people sometimes will take
this point away from discussions like
the ones that Kahneman gives when he's
distinguishing two notions of self he
calls them the experiencing self and the
remembering self and this is Daniel
Kahneman Thinking Fast and Slow that's
right and he's got a beautiful TED talk
on this but what the way that condiment
spins it and I'm partly gonna say this
because I'm gonna take it I'm gonna
disagree with karna min here he says for
example when you go on a vacation
there's the notion there is the quality
of the vacation that you get by summing
up how much you enjoyed every moment of
the vacation but then there's the story
that you tell afterwards and the story
you tell afterwards and is in some sense
dissociated from the quality of the
moments you might have enjoyed every
second just sitting on the beach doing
nothing but the kind of vacation that
people tend to tell stories about and
assess in this kind of remembering way
as the good vacations are the ones that
are chock full of activities and have
all kinds of things that they can tell
people at a dinner party that's more
than I just sat on the beach for a while
many of which many of which we're not
even that enjoyable when it assessed in
terms of the quality of the moments that
made them up so condiment thinks that
some sort of or suggests in the way he
speaks about it that there's some sort
of inauthenticity involved in in
evaluating in this sort of from the
point of view of the remembering self as
well yeah you're just telling a good
story I don't think that's right I think
what's going on there is that we each do
have these just two orthogonal
dimensions of value and we are weighing
them against one another every moment of
our lives so when you're making a
decision for example say if you say say
you woke up this morning you're in New
York it's well not a beautiful day but
it's a nice enough day you can do two
things you can spend the day doing
nothing much but wandering around maybe
having a lazy afternoon in a cafe or you
can do some New York things the kinds of
things that one is supposed to do in New
York the kinds of things exciting things
you can tell people about afterwards or
you know or you can make a contribution
to some sort of ongoing project those
weigh against one another you know I
think when you're an academic these
sorts of conflicts come up you can work
on a book something that matters to you
very much you know but isn't gonna
maximize the quality of the particular
moments that make up the day in that
sense of you know that they'll be
individually enjoyable but you will be
doing something that matters to you and
something whose value has a different
kind of value for you so I think for
human beings we have these two
relatively independent notions of value
and when we think about the value of a
human life for an extended period of a
human life it's really that second
dimension of value that's coming into
play for you - which was the second the
sort of the the period the kind of value
that has to do with plans and projects
and not with the intrinsic quality of
the moments right with keeping the past
and future in mind keeping past and
future in mind it's also the kind of
value that when we think in terms of
relationships you know there might be
some people that you end you enjoy
sitting at a table with but there's also
the kinds of
relationships that span a good period of
time and part of the value of the
relationship is that they have a certain
kind of past and they have a certain
kind of future I think again you know
those are notions of values that are to
some extent in tension with an
orthogonal to one another when a human
being dies a human being who's who's
invested a certain amount of time and a
certain amount of energy in ongoing
plans and projects and who has ongoing
relationships and there's a kind of loss
involved in that that's not just the
loss of more good moments right not just
the integral of all your happiness over
time that's right and for other people
there's a loss to because they have
invested a certain kind of continuing
relationship with that person and it's
the kind of loss that's not remediable
by having another person come into the
world
you know we've collected over the course
of our lives a very specific set of
experiences kind of thought about and
contemplated we've squeezed out of those
experiences you know a conception of who
we are and the things that we value in
the things that we care about all of
that is lost when a person is lost in
the world now arguably when it comes to
cows and I would be willing to revise
this if we found out that cows had the
kinds of minds that we did but if the
empirical hypothesis is right that cows
really don't have that kind of a
conception of their pasts and futures
and plans and projects a cow doesn't
even do much in terms of carrying over
information from one moment to the next
it just has experience it enjoys a good
meal it enjoys a sunny day yes no one is
denying that cows can have a quality of
life moment okay that can be good or bad
so on the presumption that that's all
that their lives are like
then I think the lot what the kind of
loss that happens in the world when a
cow is killed is just that there's no
more continuing experiences in that
particular stream of consciousness or
experience and that that you know that
that sort of loss is no
no worse than not bringing another cow
into existence it is remediable by the
existence of other cows and so on so
when people say you know the farming
industry is responsible for the lives
might you know of more cows and there
would be without it that's exactly right
that's true it's also sadly responsible
for a lot of suffering but putting that
aside I think there isn't there isn't a
reason not to kill a cow of the same
kind that there is not to kill a person
this is wonderful clearly I need to read
this article by velman because that I
think what you just gave me is a much
more careful and sophisticated version
of what I actually said in the podcast
that you know somehow and it reminded me
of when we were talking about intentions
and purposes and so forth somehow human
beings the reason why it's bad to kill
human being is not just because their
lives end but because you know they had
plans for the future and they had
memories of the past in in and you can
reason and again this is an empirical
idea that could be overruled if we if we
learn more about cows or octopuses or
whatever but you can reason
counterfactually with human beings you
can imagine the future and you know you
can say like not just teach the dog not
to do something but actually say ok if
you do this tomorrow I will reward you
is that's not a way you can talk to the
dog right and this ability to protect
ourselves in the future is something
that as far as I can tell is unique to
human beings and does draw a dividing
line between the ending of a life of a
human and an animal yeah and I think
it's also to me equally important that
there's a certain way in which we are
products of our past and carry our pasts
with us and carry you know our unique
personal paths with us in ways that
arguably and again this is an empirical
question that other animals at least
some other animals and probably cows
don't so there's a passage in death Aviv
an Illiad way if an alien is dying and
he's remembering he's you know going
through memories and he's saying you
know how can I die you know when I die
of course this isn't Tolstoy beautiful
language but it's the part that struck
me he says when I die how can
be some you know how can there not be
something that remembers his mother's
rustling skirts when he was young in the
world and I think there's something
really poignant about the fact that you
know when we die the collection of you
know very particular experiences and
thoughts and and not just the collection
but the selection that we've somehow
pulled together into our own story of
who we are and and kind of rescued from
the flotsam and jetsam of our own lives
that that will be gone and that won't be
replaced to me that that's who we are
you know and it's it's a very special
sort of loss you've probably heard about
peloton it's the game-changing cardio
workout that you can use in the comfort
of your own home I've tried it out the
bike what I really like is the
convenience of it the variety that you
get the fact that you can come and go in
your motivation level and when the
motivation comes it's extraordinarily
easy to just go to the bike and do your
workout there's all sorts of different
workouts available from those who are
just beginners to those who are very
very serious taught by world class
instructors who really keep you
motivated during the workout itself you
can have from one subscription multiple
profiles for different people in the
home so everyone can try it out for
themselves so you can learn more about
peloton's 30-day home trial by going to
one peloton calm that's oh and E PE l OT
o n calm and get $100 off the
accessories that you might want to get
with your bike when you purchase the
peloton bike and use promo code
mindscape that's one peloton comm use
promo code mindscape to get started if
you find you don't like the bike if it's
not right for you they offer free pickup
full refund a worry-free way to get your
exercise good so this is a very
worthwhile digression but okay we're
still where we were trying to free will
putting the putting the bow on this idea
of where the self comes from and what it
is so we distinguish between the self of
a cat and the self of a human being or a
cow
I think it connects directly with what I
just said I mean I think you know part
of the problem for understanding free
will really is understanding how to get
ourselves into the causal chain between
kind of stimulus and response and I
think it's when people talk about
freewill and they're thinking in terms
of well if you just look at you know
kind of the brain if you look at the
physical landscape all you see are the
causal chains passing through the brain
you don't see any little homunculus you
don't see you know any self entering in
there and choice right I think what I
just said about you know what we the
kinds of creatures we are the kinds of
minds that we have that we kind of
collect and distill out of the things
that happen to us you know a body of
beliefs and values and memories and so
on I think that stuff is stored in the
brain and that stuff when we make a
decision comes to play this pivotal role
in in its brought to bear you know in
the pathways between stimulus and
response and it comes to play the role
of deciding you know whether to move or
play the causal role of making a
difference between whether we move left
or right whether we do this rather than
that to me that's a clue to
understanding how it is that we get
ourselves into the causal train it's not
something that you see just by looking
at the neural level processes in the
brain you have to understand the
information that's stored in the brain
and how that information was extracted
from a very personal history of past
experience and does that also help
explain not just difference between
humans and cows but the judge from
humans and computers like could I make a
complicated looking computer that I
personally could not predict the
behavior of but nevertheless would not
want to attribute freewill - well I go
two ways on this I think it's not at all
inconceivable that we would be able to
build computers that would have exactly
this structure yeah I'm not thinking
sorry I'm not thinking in principle what
we could do someday but I'm honestly
like on my computer I can write a
program where I'm not able to predict
what the outcome is going to be but
probably my Macintosh laptop is not
going to be said to have freewill just
because I did that that's right
no that's right yeah there's no internal
decision-making process
of a kind that chooses its own goals and
develops its own personality and so on
from what you put into it we are those
kinds of things nature gives us inputs
but we do have this earth self this role
in choosing and making our own selves
and choosing goals and so on and values
and some day we could build a computer
or an Android that could also have those
capability exactly yeah and from what
you said before it would not necessarily
be a bright line that gets crossed from
not having those capabilities to having
them you sort of creep up on it I think
so I mean I think there are again going
there are all kinds of empirical
questions about about whether there is
some threshold some kind of cognitive
organization that really does mark a
kind of transition between for example
pre-linguistic and post-linguistic
mm-hmm features and that seems to me a
candidate for good divide between these
higher representational capacities that
do seem to me to be required for things
like you know freewill decision choosing
values not okay all right well this is
given a lot to think about we have the
self on the table did I leave anything
out as far as the self is concerned I
wouldn't move on to causality I think
and see and choice and think we can
always come back right so okay let's
with all that in mind good the classic
argument which i think is is not right
against freewill is just based on
determinism right if everything is
determined then our choices are
determined we're not making those
choices in some sense now there's a do
we want to spend two minutes putting
aside the question of whether or not the
laws of physics are deterministic or not
sure are they right yeah yeah yeah
depends what you mean by determinism
right yeah in part so I'm I learned from
I follow you and all that is of that
kind yes but the question of how
relevant that is to the debate about
freewill is probably the one we talk we
want to talk about
I mean probably well probably just as
just to say maybe that the the very
quick version of it is in Newtonian
physics physics was deterministic
quantum mechanics brings that into
question but whether or not quantum
mechanics is deterministic has nothing
to do with freewill right because it's
not us making the quantum choices in any
sense it's still it's not that the laws
of physics are deterministic so is that
there are impersonal laws that would be
relevant to this question is that fair
that's fair I mean I think the what I
said before about the trick is to get us
into the causal chain this brings it out
so you know if you're working in a
Newtonian regime one thinks that we
don't make the decisions because
everything is determined by the initial
conditions of the universe in a quantum
regime in the context where people think
there really are in deterministic
underlying events we don't it doesn't
help to say that the interne mystic and
underlying events together with the laws
of nature determine what we will do what
we really need to understand is how we
we determine I mean that's one way I put
it sometimes like if you're going to use
words like I and we are you in the
sentence then you have to stay you sing
the vocabulary of people doing things
you can't suddenly switch to a
vocabulary of electrons bumping into
each other and obeying the laws of
physics that's right okay good so
determinism versus non determinism is
not the question at all so much so that
for the rest of the conversation we can
just pretend the world is deterministic
at the fundamental level right and still
talk about whether it's nevertheless
possible to make decisions and have an
effect on the world yes and there's a
famous argument maybe this is a good
place to start the consequence argument
against free will and you have a very
nice summary of it in your book if you
can remember you want to say what that
is sure I mean there's so for
philosophers listening to podcast
they'll note that there are much more
complicated versions of it I'd like the
very simplest one because I think it
gets the the the persuasive force of the
argument comes out most clearly the
argument goes like this
laws of nature together sorry
if the world is deterministic the laws
of nature together with the initial
conditions of the universe determine our
actions logically determine our actions
laws of nature are not under our control
initial conditions of the universe are
not under our control therefore our
actions are not under our control sounds
pretty good it sounds like a good
argument like all the individual
statements sound good and it's a valid
conclusion right that's right so is the
way to proceed to say which of those
premises you're going to disagree with
you do you sort of want to deny that
it's a relevant way of thinking at all
so I've come to think something that I
didn't I noted in a footnote but didn't
emphasize at all in the book I've come
to think is actually crucial to really
seeing what's going wrong with that
consequence argument by the way anyone
contemplating buying your book should
know that in the middle of the book
there's a chapter called an appendix for
slackers if you didn't if you found like
some of the philosophical niceties in
the first half of the book a little bit
too intimidating there's a nice summary
in in plain language which I thought was
very very helpful I think there's even
parts of the chapters where if you don't
have the stomach for it I I signal but
there's gonna be a little bit of a picky
philosophy coming that's okay we don't
mind that yeah you can get to having
just like through all of that but the
part the point that I've come to think
is really important is you know
everybody presents the consequence
argument and in fact most discussions
are free will speaking in entirely
realistic terms and so when they say
things like I mean usually the
consequence argument just says the past
together with the laws of nature
determine how we'll act that's actually
not true in the relevant sense when we
translate it into relativistic context
and the reason is that any given
person's past or any or the past of any
given situated system even in a
deterministic context does not actually
as a matter of physical law determine
anything that falls at even a finite
fraction
a second into its future and that can
seem like it's maybe being a little
picky because it turns out that what you
need to add in order to get something
that fully as a matter of law determines
the action are events that are in what
are called the absolute elsewhere and it
can seem like the light goes outside the
light cone and it can seem like that
just means that we don't know what the
matter that we the situated agents can't
know the thoughts that are already in
place but on their way to you know
affecting us and such that if we knew
what they were or for any being that
could determine what they were would
determine our actions and I think that's
just the wrong way to think entirely
that one ought to simply acknowledge
that it's not true even in a
deterministic context that the past of
any situated system determines its
future and that there's no good sense in
which those facts the facts that are
needed to be that need to be added in
order to determine their future are
already in place well but the past of
the universe determines what's going to
happen next right so when you say that
what are you thinking you're thinking
that there is some point of view on the
universe as a whole that's kind of
all-encompassing yeah and that and by
what right do you do that I mean I am
just you know well certainly I don't
know it I don't have access to it right
but so from a God's eye view it's there
would would be the argument so there is
no literal terms there is no God that
you in literal terms there isn't well
who usually deny the existence of
freewill don't want to admit that God is
looking at the whole thing well and a
little bit stronger so even if you think
formally there's got to be some
constructible external dimension from
which the past of the world is fully
determined there is no global present in
the universe that's not even
well-defined this external point of view
is in some sense doing something very
anti relativistic yeah I'm not I'm not
really moved by that to be honest
because
I can choose this is gonna get a little
technical but what relativity tells us
is there's no unique way to divide
space-time into slices of constant time
right different people will divide it
differently so what I want to say maybe
there's some sophisticated reason why I
shouldn't and you'll tell me what it is
but what I want to say is that's okay
pick a way slice up the universe into
moments of time and I can imagine
knowing what the what is going on on one
slice of constant time one space like
hypersurface as we say and that
determines everything inside its domain
of dependence I read everything in his
future and past isn't that good enough
well we want to do here so it depends
for the purposes of free will what one
wants to understand is what lies in the
causal past in a sense that can act as a
constraint on your action that's the
whole force of the consequence argument
people are thinking the past is fixed
and beyond our control for those
purposes I think one ought to stick to
the relativistically well-defined past
the things that possibly could constrain
and that are beyond your control and
that can constrain and act causally as
influences on your decisions but doesn't
that mean that whether or not the
consequence argument works is different
in Newtonian physics than in relativity
good okay so the reason I started with
the relativistic setting is because I
think it's a little easier to understand
that setting okay so I think it is still
true in the case it is true sorry in RL
in a Newtonian regime that you can say
there is a fact about the total state of
the world whether or not we know it it's
a little complicated to to sort of
unpack what I want to say about that in
in literal terms but I think what I want
to I mean I'll put it very briefly there
it's not the case that there's ever in
space and time an AMA logically
sufficient body effect in Newtonian
setting to determine what you'll do
before any collection of facts can be
nama logically linked to your
an event or action at some future time
you need to add that there are no other
facts or events in addition to those
that you've already counted for you're
gonna have to define the word Noma
logically for us Noma logically means as
a matter of physical law okay okay
so in also it's not the case that
there's ever anything in the relevant
sense in a Newtonian regime that is as a
matter of physical law sufficient to
determine an action at some future time
in order to get that you have to add
this sort of negative fact that there
are no other facts in place and the
status of those kinds of negative facts
which we probably shouldn't go into a
conversation about right now is the
thing I think on which you can hinge a
plot you know the denial that that
there's ever anything fixed and already
in place there's ever enough fixed it in
place to determine an action as a matter
of physical law okay I would I mean
that's a very that's a very interesting
argument I'm gonna have to think about
but it's a different one that I expected
you to give maybe just cuz I'm
prejudiced by what my own argument is
like I would have said something like
the premises of the consequence argument
make perfect sense if your Laplace is
demon if you could in principle know
everything about the past and have
perfect calculational ability but none
of us is so the way that actually human
beings get to actually talk about the
world given the information we actually
have about it the laws of physics and
the past do not determine the future
because that those that's not the kind
of law like behavior we have access to
in the macroscopic emergent world is
that is that a family cousin to what you
said or the family cousins except I've
come to think that it's really important
that there's not even and and it's
clearest again in the relativistic
context there's not even information
that could in principle be accessed by a
laplacian demon that would be sufficient
to determine what you will do at some
future time if that demon lies in your
own path yeah okay interesting because I
just say well you're not Laplace is
demon so I don't care and you're saying
even
if you are the plaza demon it's not
enough so that's a stronger or yes
certain yes okay and so is that it is
that you know is that your that's why
the consequence argument doesn't work no
it that what that does so a lot of this
is kind of ground clearing um you know
it clears away sort of you know the
thing that people always want to say in
these contexts whenever you come up with
the sort of high-level description that
I think that you event the size and that
I try to give in the book of what it is
to make a decision and what that looks
like through the lens of physics people
will vary and you know for the reasons
that you say you know given the kind of
information that we have and so on that
it makes sense to describe things at
that level people will you know kind of
hardliners will always come along and
say yes but in principle there's this
microscopic description what I just said
just an argument to clear that away and
say as a matter of physics it's not even
true and that places the emphasis where
I think it should be for the purposes of
talking about processes like decision
and understanding ourselves and so on
namely on the high level processes that
that you emphasize and that I emphasize
in the book so in some sense you're
saying even if I buy everything you want
me to buy it still doesn't work and
doesn't work as a matter of physics I
mean I think the tenor of those
arguments is very often
oh you soft humanistically just you know
people you know you're just not
understanding the physics and the retort
is you know yeah all right so let's
let's take that as at least I don't want
to I'm not judging here but that is very
street I think it's a very
understandable response to the
consequence argument so where does that
leave us I mean what is it what does it
mean given our previous discussion about
what it means to be yourself and have
intentions and so forth do we need to do
more work to understand what it means to
make a choice what it means to have a
causal impact on the world yes so the
notion of causation is one that's
absolutely central to these discussions
so the way that I set it up in the book
and which I I really do think it's right
for addressing the con the conversation
as it's played out in the philosophical
literature
and probably in a lot of people's minds
when they first encountered the argument
in kind of you know public discussions
people are importing causal notions into
their understanding of the physics that
in some ways I think the physics itself
doesn't employ those notions doesn't
support the employment of those notions
in that capacity and it's important to
talk people through the ways in which
notions of physical law and notions like
causation really do get literal
application in physics and I think what
happens so I'll say a little bit I think
about what people are thinking when they
think of notions of natural necessity
they have in mind
causal notions kind of borrowed from
their experience of like pulling and
pushing and yanking and they think that
when you say that you know some event in
the past or some collection of events in
the past or as in the consequence
argument the past itself as a matter of
physical law determines you know some
event or some collection of events in
the future is there imagining that
there's a sort of causal force emanating
from the initial conditions of the
universe and pushing later events into
place now as a matter of just physical
law and I know this is something that
you've talked about on podcasts the
physical laws themselves are entirely
time-reversal invariant which means they
don't have a built in direction of
determination if the past determines the
future in the kind of deterministic
context that Newtonian mechanics
provides just equally and in exactly the
same way the future determines the past
so the notion of you know nomological or
law like determination isn't strong
enough to get us the kind of a symmetric
relation of determination that we want
causes precede effect yeah so people are
thinking in causal terms they're
importing those causal notions into
their understanding of physical law so
that's a legitimate but let's look at
the notion of causation then and see
whether we can understand in the
terms how causal notions get in and
whether it's right to say you know that
the that our pasts causally determine
our futures and they're there's a lot of
work to be done and I tried to do it in
the book gets a kind of extended notion
of the ways in which causal notions have
changed over the course of you know
physical you know physics coming to
understand it is weird to me you know we
talked to Ned hall about causation a
little bit I'm writing a paper on
causation right now is amazingly the
extent to which this very simple kind of
everyday thing that Aristotle put at the
center of everything 2500 years ago it's
something we still understand and partly
it's because you know we know a lot more
physics now and there's sort of work to
be done mapping the physics on to the
folk wisdom or the manifest image but
there were people like Bertrand Russell
who said the best thing you do is just
get rid of the notion of cause and
effect
you've you and other people have said
well that's going too far yeah yeah so
the reason that Russell said that was
the one that I just pointed to together
with a lot of collection of other sort
of niceties of the physics but the pre
theoretic notion of cause the notion of
cause the common sense brings to its
understanding of the connections between
events there's nothing like that if one
just looks at the fundamental equations
of motion so that's why Russell said we
should push it aside with the advancing
tides of science it's an image it's the
sign of an immature science if it uses
notions like that y'all wish we could
write like Bertrand Russell but rightly
many years later Nancy Cartwright came
along and pointed out that in fact the
notion of cause is not dispensable for
purposes of understanding the difference
between relations between events in
particular correlations of a kind that
are entailed by law that we can use the
strategic route for bringing about ends
with ones that aren't and that's
absolutely central to understanding you
know how it is that we can intervene in
and affect the world
absolutely central to practical
reasoning and so then that began a long
philosophical project of trying to
recover from these time-symmetric
underlying laws together with auxiliary
facts about the world how it is that we
can re important notions into physics
and that's something that's come into
focus more in a kind of revolution in
causal thinking that's happened in the
last 2530 years and that's really done a
whole lot I think to make respectable
and to firm up and to separate from all
of the phenomenological associations the
notion of cause and make it you know
something that we can use in a
preferment precise way in in scientific
context and I think a lot of it a lot of
this whole discussion really involves
you know again levels and emergence in
the sense that we made a lot of progress
on fundamental physics and the image
were left with the fundamental physics
is very very different than our image of
the everyday world and there's at least
a little bit of temptation for people to
say well but fundamental physics is
right that's the language we should use
and others including I guess us and Dan
Dennett and other people are saying you
know but now there's really an car right
there's useful information in these
patterns that we notice in the
macroscopic world so sure you could be
Laplace's demon or maybe you could be
the flosses demon and make predictions
but not only are none of us actually
Laplace this demon but nevertheless we
do not lack the ability to make
predictions because there are emergent
patterns that only work at the higher
level and it's just not only wasteful
but wrong to pretend that those patterns
are no longer real in fact in many cases
they're the more illuminating ones and
not just because they're simpler to use
for constructing predictions but partly
for reasons that point back to you know
what I was saying about the emergence of
creatures like us in order to understand
how a world that's governed at the micro
physical level by things like Newtonian
laws produces the kinds of systems that
we are you need to understand something
like evolution and you need to
understand that what evolution selects
for
is very often high-level processes so I
think the more illuminating pattern is
going to be the one that pays attention
to the kinds of processes that
evolutionary mechanisms select for
evolution doesn't care about atoms in
some sense right and more of if you look
around us the sorts of systems that we
see around us aren't you know a
representative sample of the possible
configurations of atoms that you would
get by recombining them in any which way
they're very particular kinds of
collections of them and in order to
understand why those ones exists and not
others you need to understand what they
do and how they understanding yes
exactly yeah
okay so we have a vision of what selves
are and they're these messy things that
have adapted to be able to have
intentions and purposes and function in
the world in certain ways and we have a
little bit of notion that it still makes
sense to talk about having a causal
impact on the world is there a way in
which we talk about the causal impact of
selves well let's say Israel do we
conclude then at the end of the day
human beings have causal effects on the
world in different ways than cows do and
this is something that we can label
freedom of choice it's okay if I back up
a little because there is something that
we didn't say when we were talking about
causation that I think needs to be said
which is that this cleaned-up notion of
causation is a very kind of permissive
notion but one thing that it doesn't
have built into it is the kind of notion
of compulsion that comes from our
everyday notions of cause what it does
is effectively if you take a set of
variables and you fix some of the gross
constraints in the environment and you
intervene on one of the variables the
causal information is information about
the effects that intervening on that
variable has on the other variables in
the network so we can talk in a kind of
way that is entirely neutral about and
crosses levels about one thing having a
causal impact on another thing and I
think when we're talking about freedom
of the will we were really trying to
understand
and how the kinds of voluntary behaviors
or the kinds of intentions that we form
can have a causal impact on the
environment this notion of causation is
very well suited to play that role but
it's not different in kind than the kind
of causal impact then say you know a cow
can have by kicking over a bucket those
can make things happen your house can
make things happen so I think when we're
talking about freewill we're
specifically interested in the ways in
which our intentions and decisions can
impact the movements of things in the
world okay and so I just want say
elaborate on that I mean what is what is
special about intentions and decisions
that distinguishes the way a human being
is talking from the way a cow acts okay
so again I'm going to go back to the
earlier discussion so when I said that
there is a way where you can look at you
know any kind of mind as just a part of
the causal landscape that the causal
paths pass through so I like to think
about because it's one of the kind of
models of a mind that's fairly well
understood and that's discussed a lot in
the biological literature think of a cow
a frog brain instead of a hat okay yeah
so frogs have these really
well-developed evolutionarily
beautifully-designed mechanisms which
are such that a certain kind of pattern
hits its retina it will snap out its
tongue because that ret that kind of
pattern typically indicates a passing
fly and the tongue will snap it out in
and bring it up and so there's some
sense in which the behavior of the frog
is a product of things that it does but
in another sense in another sense it's
not because the frog's brain has been
designed in evolutionary time in order
to produce that stimulant that responds
in the presence of this stimulus human
minds are different for a lot of the
reasons that we said you know we the
things that we do aren't simply a
product of the ways in which the hard
structure in our heads was designed by
evolutionary processes our minds were
designed to be the sort of information
socks we pull up information that's
collected not over kind of
evolutionary time and built into the
hard structure of our brains but over
personal time and built into the soft
structure of our brains and when we make
a decision it's those bodies of
information and those bodies of
information again that haven't just been
collected and made an impact or an
imprinted on our brains but been
collected and sorted through and
contemplated and from which we've
extracted hopes and dreams and so on
those are the things that get brought to
bear on behavior so I like to put it in
terms of you know what goes on in our
minds in Contra distinction to what goes
on in a frog mind or possibly a cow mind
generically and characteristically in
context where we're making decisions
plays a pivotal role in in what we end
up doing and by that I mean irrespective
of what the stimulus is what goes on in
our minds is going to make a difference
to doing a or doing be very frog every
time that kind of stimulus passes by
it's going to produce the same behavior
and it's going to produce that behavior
without any kind of self conscious
rumination on its part I think I think
this is a really really crucial point I
mean animals can learn things right you
can train rats to run mazes and so forth
but all animals including human beings
have impulses instincts natural things
but maybe human beings have this unique
ability to overwrite our natural
impulses just by thinking about it right
just by cogitation or reflection or
whatever not not by necessarily being
trained and that that changes what we
mean when it comes to choice and free
will that's right and it may be you know
more of a graded scale then you know
then it's indicated on those brief
remarks I mean we know things like you
know that cows can construct maps of
mazes and things like that so there's
surely some kind of rudimentary
information processing and something
that looks like decisions and
representation going on in the minds of
all kinds of lower animals and this is
also help us understand the cases of you
know in freewill discussions there's
famous cases of
people who had a brain tumor that forced
them to do something in a very
predictable and way that they just
couldn't help it in some sense and is is
it fair in those cases to say those
people don't have free will because they
can't help but do that in a predictable
way not not with respect to those
behaviors so we're particularly I mean
we're we exhibit our freedom you know in
the most highly developed form is in the
context of decision when we're making
deliberate choices and it's precisely
because those are the kinds of cases
that engage this whole machinery of
bringing your hopes and dreams and all
of the things that you identify with
from a first personal point of view to
bear I mean you know we don't control
the reflexes that our knees you know so
and so it's really it's anything that
bypasses those decision post yeah we
don't control our heartbeats right
you've non controlled things as long as
there are some controlled things okay
and control specifically by that you
know sir first personal kind of decision
level processes right okay and I guess
you know just sort of wrap it up then
clearly this whole discussion has a
relationship to questions of moral
responsibility and blame and praise and
things like that is it just a one-to-one
correlation you know like if to the
extent that we have free will we have
responsibility for our actions or is it
more subtle than that but it's it's
complex and subtle in a way that
reflects the real complexity and
subtlety of questions of moral
responsibility so it's a feature of this
kind of account rather than a bug that
it recognizes that you know there's some
extent to which who we are is a product
of these sort of reflective processes
but it's also true that's partly not and
in many cases people really don't have
the right sorts of opportunities to
develop the kind of autonomous self that
that makes them responsible so all of
the cases that you think of as the gray
cases when you're thinking about moral
responsibility people who had horrible
upbringing they're impaired emotionally
they're impaired cognitively they're in
one way or not
handicapped from really developing the
sort of self-determination that one
thinks when needs um those really are
great cases I think you were tempted to
say it's not their fault exactly exactly
and it's perfectly valid that in some
cases that would be right it's not their
fault and that's a hard not wholly their
fault yeah and you know all of the ways
in which you feel yourself pulled two
ways are probably ways in which you know
the facts are pulling in different
direction do you think I mean is it is
there an argument to be made that if you
didn't believe in free will
it would hard it would be hard to have
discussions about morality and
responsibility at all like after all if
we're just determined by everything then
how could you blame anybody for anything
that's a hard one yeah I mean praise and
blame you know I I blame my car when it
doesn't do the thing I want it to do
moral praising for worldly yeah moral
praise and blame in a sense that license
is punishment again maybe there are
social uses for these things even if
they're not you know so I even if
they're even if you can't give a
philosophical arguments that something
deserves to be praised or blamed so I
you know I don't have a clear answer to
those things above my paygrade that's
fine but the rubber does hit the road in
these philosophical discussions when it
comes to like legal questions right like
who gets blamed who do we say is had the
ability to do otherwise right that that
philosophical question is very very
relevant to who we put in jail and who
we don't for some people you know some
people might say it's irrelevant that
the legal system there is there to
create deterrence and constraints that
that you know condition or keep other
people from doing bad things
irrespective of whether the people we
punished deserve it in that fully well
maybe maybe the safer thing to say is
that people having those discussions
would benefit from a more nuanced
philosophical understanding of yeah
absolutely and because both of us and
all good thinking people I think there
is such a thing as free will and these
the most discussions should be
deeply steeped in trying to understand
the sorts of control that we have and
and in cases where we fail to have that
kind so I always like to end on an
optimistic note to the extent that
that's realistic given the subject
matter so you already mentioned the last
25 years or whatever a revolution in
reasoning about causality clearly
psychology cognitive science and
neuroscience are moving at an amazing
speed and even philosophy I would argue
you know is seeing a lot of progress do
you think that in these issues of the
very broad program of connecting physics
to our emergent everyday lives we're
making real progress and is the progress
seeping out into the larger world for
sure I think we're making progress I
mean I think you know this is really a
kind of golden era for a genuine kind of
scientifically respectable naturalistic
view of the human being there's been for
a long time these sorts of naysayers and
including people who present themselves
as kind of defenders of science you say
there is no such thing as free will
we've just got to like sort of open our
eyes and so on but I think now there
really is coming into focus are really
plausible and persuasive view of the
human being with all of its enchantment
and amazingness and so on is it seeping
out into the wider world funny enough I
think it's probably seeping out into the
public more quickly than it is into
philosophy rooted in very traditional
ways of thinking as the human being and
thinking of you know thinking of
Enchantment in a way that's
anti-scientific listen isn't uh if I
remember the the survey that David
Chalmers good don't most philosophers
classify themselves as compatible lists
when it comes to free will I think they
do ok I think that's right ok but still
but you're saying in the in the general
project of connecting the underlying
scientific image to the everyday life
they're still falling behind it's still
finding it's still a little bit chanted
yeah well ok good it's good that there's
still room for progress otherwise you
wouldn't have anything to do exactly a
very optimistic message all right do you
notice by EL thank you so much for
choosing to be
on the mindscape podcast thanks so much
for having me it's been a pleasure
[Music]
you
[Music]